Antonia al de ella has been unemployed
for more than five years just like her
husband and her son the family from
Barcelona lives from her husband's
pension they don't receive social
welfare payments they can't meet their
mortgage payments and they're threatened
with repossession and eviction at the
moment we have to pay almost nine
hundred euros to the bank but we don't
have it and if we did no money would be
left over not for food or anything else
protests are held frequently in front of
bank branch offices in the centre of
Barcelona since the crisis began
thousands of Spaniards are threatened
with eviction I have a little
three-year-old daughter when I got
pregnant I was fired just like that
there was a bit of back and forth but
ultimately I was out on the street
there's even see a doctor
yeah I mean raucous here at the moment
I'd do anything no matter what as long
as I get paid Spain is currently one of
the countries in Europe with the highest
unemployment rate about 23% only Greece
has a higher proportion of jobless
people twenty five percent but European
statistics count school pupils and
students as unemployed losing your job
in Greece is especially threatening
unemployment benefits run out after 12
months and then there's no more help
from the state Greece has no social
welfare insurance since the crisis began
many companies especially small and
mid-sized businesses have trouble
getting credit from the bank
at this print shop near Athens that
means the owner can't invest in new
machines or hire new people don't know
me no she up to now I haven't had to let
anyone go keep people on board as long
as possible there is work to be done we
try to offer customers lower prices and
discounts but it's still a big effort to
find work for all my employees then what
we've done is to reduce the hours in
their work week we used to work in three
shifts now we do less is a man under the
ocean the further north you go in Europe
the lower the unemployment rate in
France it's currently at a little more
than ten percent the French government
has made job creation its top goal but
so far without much success as long as
the economy doesn't recover and the
country doesn't become competitive again
job creation initiatives won't help much
suppose you book with evolution I
haven't noticed any fundamental change I
think it's getting harder and harder to
find a job there is still work out there
but you have to really make an effort
it's hard to find something mystical
ecology dilemma the physician but I
don't expect to get a job here I already
tried everything I could before I came
here to the job centre at ten percent
unemployment France is in the middle of
the European range Germany has Europe's
lowest unemployment rate about five
percent northern and southern Europe are
drifting apart
Spain is seeing the first encouraging
signs in the labor market the economy is
very gradually recovering in March the
number of unemployed fell by about
60,000